hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for
well the moment you've all been waiting
for has already passed but I'm just
gonna show you a nice fraction of the
moment you've all been waiting waiting
for it's the finals of the banter blitz
coupons just 24 oh it has a future
versus magnus carlsen to battle it out
for the first price of $14,000 which is
not not not bad for an online event
definitely and well now both of them
defeated a lot of opponents to read you
this point and a lot is at stake here as
well it's hard to say but pretty much
pretty much no one can challenge Magnus
Carlsen to any time format but when it
comes to lower time formats holidays is
definitely the one who could maybe so
this is one of the games I'd chose I
hope you enjoy it and if you want to
check out all the other games as all of
them were just you know nail-biting
action I will put a link to this in the
description below it will be the first
thing you will see I will take you to
just 24s website where you can check out
all the games and you can even watch a
cross and stream and also it has a
stream there so let's check it out with
the white pieces of a razor opens with E
4 with a 5 by Magnus and now comes
Knight to c3 and it's interesting ali
reza countered Carlson's sicilian also
with two knights the c3 and here against
Eovaldi reza also goes for Knight to c3
the vienna game magnus replies knight to
f6 and Bishop to c4 now we have Knight
to c6 by Magnus and b3 now we have nice
to a5 immediately cross and goes for the
light square Bishop he wants to win that
bishop pair Bishop to b3 Knight captures
a cactus in the now d5 of course
striking in the center we have Knight to
f3 ali reza develops the night d
captures on e4 Knight captures on e5 e
capture sun d3 and now there is one game
from 1987 where Queen Catherine b3 was
played between Thomas and Khalif man but
here ollie Reza just castles and it is
as a move 9 that we have a completely
new game so what's happening here point
is of course you cannot capture and grab
another pawn because of characters
capers and captures let's just check you
you're gonna lose the Ruby there so
instead of the
seven by Magnussen just continuous
development prepares the castle and
nowadays a wins back at the pawn Knight
captures on d3 and after all is said and
done magnus carlsen has the bishop pair
whereas ali reza does not have the
bishop pair but he has some nice
development the Knights are nicely
placed in the game the rook has a semi
open a file which means you can either
use it on the FL or you can quickly
shift it over to the Kings side or in
the center depending on what black plays
but definitely a trade off we have
castles by black and Queen to f3 just
nicely developing preventing back from
developing the light square bishop so c6
blocking the Queen's attacked at a b7
pawn and now h3 not allowing any Bishop
to g4 action we have looked yet by
Magnus and rook to d1 now maybe
threatening some nasty discoveries but
for the moment that there aren't any so
Magnus not all that excited Bishop to e6
just continues development and Bishop to
e3 now and now cross and wants to
connect rooks so Queen to C 7 and of
course you cannot go after the a7 pawn
with the bishop or with the rook doesn't
really matter now because at some point
the bush will become try but it's not
it's not as straightforward as it looks
because after captures captures and
captures you can trap the bishop however
white can defend it and after update you
have this silly Knights to b5 move which
you have to take in in in consider into
consideration but black will always be
better for example Queen b7
and now c4 you just strengthen there
that night here again you cannot capture
because of just captures and now you
have to find Bishop to d5 and then you
will be able to use your advantage
because after characters and captures
now on b5 now you will either capture
the bishop or White has this d6 move
which forces a queen trade and after
Bishop captures
now you will play some like Bishop to b8
and pick up the bishop I know it's it's
a lot to go on but it's really funny so
I decided to show it so instead all the
rest goes to Bishop to f4 forces Carlsen
to find another square for the Queen and
now Queen back to see it Carson doesn't
want to go Bishop to d6 which is
probably better
as you don't have to again disconnect
your looks but it forces cousin to give
up the bishop pair so we have Queen back
to c8 by Magnus and now Bishop to e5 now
getting more more spacing with the
bishop and also freeing the f4 square
for the knight if needed with Knight to
d7 it forces the bishop back brush it
back to d4 and now b6 by Magnus he wants
to play c5 and kick this Bishop all the
way to a three but it has a place the
the nicely and maneuvered Knight to e4
which frees the c3 square for his Bishop
so Magnus goes c5 with Russia back to c3
and now there's a there there's the
issue of how do you develop because you
cannot go Knight to f6 the White has
simply too much control of the f6 square
so here Magnus instead goes f6 it looks
ugly but if it works why not it numbs
the bishop on c3 and also against more
control of the e5 square but as you gain
something you lose something you lost
control of the e6 squared so ali reza
immediately goes for Knight to f4
attacks the blusher brush up to f7 and
now rook the b2 you could immediately
win the bishop pair with Knight to d6
force black to capture but reza prefers
to double up on the d file with knights
the f8 by magnus and now comes Luke 8 d1
just doubling up rooks and now Queen to
c7 again a Magnus connect rooks he's
ready to go rook a to d8 trade off the
Brooks and his position will be will be
very good as he does have the bishop
pair however here ali reza goes the
Queen to g3 and here Magnus really
started wasting a lot of time as there
are a lot of tricks here for example
there's all this pressure along the the
G file and the ideas like Knight
captures and f6 come to mind for example
if you if you try something weird like
rook a to d8 you just get Knight
captures on f6 and after Bishop captures
just Bishop captures on f6 which comes
with the mate threat and also you're
gonna lose the rook here so here after
all is said and done 96 defends against
mate
you would have to trade here Queen
captures on a4 rook captures any age
with check and after
like I said everything is said and done
you will get get out of this or being of
the exchange so that's kind of the
problem with Queen to g3 this is just
it's hard to parry this and if you try
something like king HH to get away from
from this problem then you just run into
Nigeria and you lose the Queen and c7 so
not not great
so what Carson should have done here is
Knight to e6 but it's incredibly hard
move to find in a 3 + 2 minute game if
if someone is just tuning in these are
blitz games three plus three minutes
plus two seconds increment problem is
that after Knight the e6 now white no
longer has this and ID captures on f6
Bishop captures and Bishop captures
because you are now free to capture the
night as this Knight is guarding g7 so
there is no mate so this would would
have been good for black however Magnus
went Queen to c6 now puts pressure on
the e4 Knight here but it doesn't work
and also it defends the f6 pawn one more
time but again like I said it doesn't
work but feel free to pause the video
and try to figure out why it doesn't
work while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
successfully beating Magnus Carlsen in a
blitz game and for those who if you just
want to enjoy the show both Knight to d6
and Knight to f6 work Knight to f6 is
more straightforward Knight to d6 just
goes away with a different plan that you
want to bring your rook here but if you
found rook teresa's then both of the
ideas work all it is I went for Knight
characters on f6 would check Magnus
capture and now you don't allow the
Queen to defend just a rook to d6 and
now Magnus is in a lot of trouble he
played Queen to e4 but now Bishop
captures on f6 threatens mate
Magnus goes Knight to g6 he defends
against mate and also threatens the
window knight here and also threatens
now to pick up the bishop but Alireza
finds the strongest move Knight to h5
problem is that Magnus cannot capture
the bishop because of Knight captures
here just the forks the king and the
Queen and also the rook doesn't really
matter but it is a nice fork definitely
so after Knight h5 Queen captures and c2
by Magnus you have to move the Queen
now there is the threat of capturing the
bishop but now our razor just grabs the
pawn on g7 we have Bishop captures and
b3 and now Bishop back to c3 getting the
bishop out of harm's way and now
preparing Knight to f6 check so rook the
e7 getting the rook out of harm's way
so the check doesn't connect we have
Knight to f6 check King to f7 by Magnus
and now Knight captures on h7 and now
with the King so wide open it's it's
hard to survive against anyone
especially against all erisa
here Magnus went for rook 88 brought
another look into the game put some
pressure on the e-file but the bishop
from c3 is beautifully guarding against
everything and he rallied as I continued
Knight to g5 just for the for the beauty
of it I will ask you to pause the video
one more time because there is a forced
mating in five moves here so do feel
free to find it if you if you feel like
it well I'll give you a couple of
seconds so if you found that really
congratulations you are an excellent
mater in five and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
it's rook to f6 now a point being if you
go here you no longer defend the night
and then it's just a free night with
check so not much to go on here and if
you go King g7 it's even worse because
now while you defend the night you go
under the bishops mask so rook captures
simply king characters here and now rook
g7 again with check if rook captures
Queen captures is made to have to move
and now Queen h4 check forces the Queen
to retreat and now delivers checkmate so
this was in the position however time is
low so Knight g5 check we have King to
g8 and now Knight to e4 check
sorry Knight to e4 again the king is
away from the defense of the night so
the two ideas simply connect you move
the knight to block the Queen's defense
while the Queen can capture the night
which is what Magnus played
rook captures on g6 with check King to
f8 and the now comes rook D to D sex
preparing disrupted to start delivering
checks we looked at F seven by Magnus
and now rook G to f6 instead we have
King the e7 now with ideas that well you
want to do something although it's very
hard to
decide what you want to play a movie
that doesn't lose while there very long
time but here all it has a simple played
rock actress on f7 check and it was in
this position that magnus carlsen
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here if you capture with
the king then it's Queen g7 mate and if
you capture with the bishop which is
much seems like a nice idea then the
idea is Bishop to f6 with check the rook
simply prevents the King from going
anywhere you have to go here and again
Queen g7 is made so really a remarkable
game beautiful game by both of them
shame for Magnus he didn't find that
Knights the e6 defensive idea but
already played a brilliant attacking
game so so brilliant we could even award
a more fee head here definitely we
should there we go Eliza the Murphy head
is all yours then using the Vienna
really really a nice touch that Knight
to c3 really really brought in a nice
victory
so I guess the wins wins the game and
also wins the entire event he wins the
$14,000 and like I said if you want to
check out all the games to do check it
out it will be the link in the
description below first thing you will
see really enjoyable
like I said nail-biting action and it
was uh it was a it wasn't
well if I had to like really break down
the match Alireza was winning the entire
match at some point Magnus took over the
lead but only for one game and then oh
it as I went back into inter leading the
match and it seemed like Carlson was
really nervous like every game he it
seems like he was doubting himself all
the time he even said sets of himself so
you can you can only imagine how strong
Alvarez is at this well fast time form
it's like like three minute blitz and
and especially bullet he's just a
monster in bullet so really amazing and
even though who know Crossan hasn't lost
a class for him in like maybe 120 games
now I really lost count but in the end
these faster games Alireza will
definitely be stirring a lot of trouble
and not only in the future but also
already so Magnus will have his chance
for revenge as Alvarez is also playing
in the Magnus cross and Invitational
which which starts in three
the first two grants will be on the
weekend so that's gonna be very exciting
and yeah like I said I do check out all
the other games in the description below
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank William Avery
James for cut and Nicolae spelled here
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga the lila and
stockfish saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent race today